[Music]
hi i'm greg
and i'm john we're the real rejects how
you guys doing i
i'm still so i'm just tripping balls
right now
double trouble oh my god this is awesome
to be talking to you too right now
we're literally we're just laughing our
asses off at your i installed every gta
mod video
we literally got to the very end with
godzilla
king kong floating off into a plane that
was a
that was that was some fun stuff and
that there was definitely some risky
stuff in it too like a teletubbie aiding
human beings
yeah i feel like we should be looking
way upward i'm just going to use our
whole interview time saying that
this is so great you don't have to say
anything
i feel great just keep the compliments
going yeah all right
nice to meet you guys nice to meet you
cool youtube channel oh thank you so
much thank you we have officially
succeeded
we don't need anything for you guys we
need to
clip that put it on the internet i
notice we haven't heard any compliments
from you ninja what's going on
it's an honor to be talking with you and
we i love this movie
i mean you are the fifth person we're
talking to yeah i know when you
like see ninja here man that's when a
special dude no this is more special we
you're the only one who's video we
watched before
on this very sincere note uh we were
both surprised by how much we love this
movie
no hyperbolic way at all you guys were
really great in the movie you guys were
awesome
you guys were really great so happy to
hear that because obviously you know
when i watched it i was like i i really
like it but also i'm in it so maybe i'm
biased so
glad you're having another group of
people that you guys also loved it
something that can come to mind for us
when we see a like a streamer pop up in
a movie or something or like
oh here we go and then we were like oh
no they're actually really good so
congratulations
man thank you um i am insanely talented
so uh it makes a lot of sense that i was
naturally just amazing i had acted
before but i was amazingly good at it
i did it all in one take it was
incredible he'd never say anything
i would i would i would concur with
these statements laser because
actually but john why don't you can't
you ask the laser team the first
question today absolutely i mean you
know throughout the movie we're cutting
back and forth to your reactions and
your commentary as you're experiencing
the game and so
just out the gate what was your reaction
when they contacted you to be in this
and what was that like toki
when we start with you it was just so
surreal and exciting i mean
ryan reynolds a hollywood film
me like makes things i truly never
thought would make so
absolutely like once in a lifetime super
exciting opportunity i had to say yes
instantly there are some things that
don't come
okay i mean how do i wear this there are
things that come across your desk or
just like
it's like oh you've got a lot of things
i'm like nah nah nah very rarely do you
get something where it's just like
instant yes and that was that was this
for
for clearly clearly for both of us it
was like no thinking required really
oh that's awesome so right away no
suspicion that it was fake at all
like yeah absolutely no we found it out
a little bit
made some calls and then when
that's great we did our due diligence
and then instantly
it was kind of dubious at first i think
whenever you're
asked to be in stuff because we get tons
of emails all the time of people being
like hey want to collaborate
and sell our power generators from
like somewhere in the world actual email
i got but
when something like this comes through
it's like there's no way this is way too
cool to
like be a real thing that's happening
but then after talking about it a bit
and then
getting the director's phone number
being able to chat with them wow
yeah big time but i feel like i don't
know it's still weird because it was
supposed to come out a while ago
and we've seen it for a while now at
this point so for us it feels like it
kind of came out already and now
everyone's hyping it up again
it's gonna be weird to go to the cinema
and have everyone like tweet at us and
send us messages yeah
yeah similar for me i joined a little
bit later than the rest of the guys
so everything was a bit more set in
stone so when i got the same
a similar email with the number for the
director set up a call the day after
again skeptical because the email was
like super casual it wasn't real
short phone call with the director he
was like let's do this can you film it
this time
did it it was all like with our own
setup and stuff as well so it was super
easy to do
and yeah fun fun film to be involved
with it was definitely surprising
because i was just sitting in my bedroom
making fortnite videos in like early
2019 grinding away not sleeping ever
so to get that phone call was very weird
because i'm like why do you want this
weird australian dude in your movie
but once it was sort of explained and
like i had the meeting i was like hell
yeah i mean i mean i was saying yes from
the first phone call but yeah
you know it started to make sense as
soon as you had that first conversation
but like going over there
sitting on the film set and having all
these people
staring at you and expecting you to you
know perform and stuff was very
terrifying but they're such a welcoming
and like good wholesome group of people
so like it was so yes they made it so
easy
this movie it periodically checks back
into your live streams as you're
experiencing the game and as the plot
progresses
your emotional engagement in the game
progresses so
as easy as it can be for someone to say
you guys are just doing what you
normally do you're actually having to
deliver like real acting performances
and have to be as real as possible so
i'm very curious like what was the
filming process like was it all scripted
did it let you improvise were you
surrounded by a film crew
what i mean what was it like yeah i was
really really appreciative of
how much leeway they gave us to
improvise where they did tell us
hey this is the context of the scene
these are some lines that we think you
might say
you can try delivering on those if
there's anything that you think
you would rather say or is more in line
of how you usually stream
then you can try those as well and
that's the beauty of
you know movies and editing you can take
a billion
takes 100 yeah
and i you know i leave it up to the
editors who definitely know what they're
doing
that's true i mean you guys are so used
to streaming yeah bro it's always cool
when they're just like hey just go like
you know just just they'll be like okay
action boom you do the same thing line
the action they tweak it a little bit
same thing and then they're like all
right do something random
and then they're like it's like and then
like so it's like now you just do some
random [ __ ] and then like sometimes like
sometimes that's the one that's the team
that's awesome gonna be like a cutting
room floors worth of deleted tapes
oh yeah bro right i think i had a scene
where i was actually like in
like the streets in the game not just
being like myself playing ninja
um so i was out there in boston when
they were filming it was just super
lenient super laid back right like
obviously there was a script that they
wanted us to
they can nail the points uh you know
constantly mentioning of course you know
free guy ryan reynolds you know a blue
shirt guy all that stuff other than that
man it was really like
you know sean was like this is you
you're like this is your language
like you're playing you speak how you
would speak and
uh it was dude it was not difficult
right
awesome it was very relaxing yeah for me
that's awesome we had the
description of what the tr like what
we're reacting to
was going to be but we didn't have the
footage so there was that i guess
element of acting but then you're also
being yourself so you're just kind of
trying to reenact what you would react
to or how you would react to that clip
so that was a little bit challenging but
we literally just i did it like
10 times different ways the script was
there
but uh sean the director allowed us to
be as loose as
we wanted to be with it to be
supernatural yeah that was a challenge
to it to not overact
but it was just being ourselves really
that's great
there's a little element to it where
it's like you think being yourself is
is like incredibly freeing and it was
but you kind of get in your head about a
day and be like well how do i normally
act because normally you have like the
thing in front of you that you're
reacting to and everything sort of
improvised so
you don't really know how you are it's
just kind of going with the flow of it
so having to like sit down and deliver
lines
as you it's a little jarring but
the fact that we didn't have to be on
set we didn't have to
be with like a crew we weren't wasting
anyone's time the director wasn't there
like yelling
action or cut or anything like that so
we kind of just got to go at our own
pace and as long as we
gave a performance that they felt like
was natural to us then
it was all golden so they they literally
let you just
film it yourself you didn't have to have
like a crew involved at all like this is
really just
as if you're doing your own thing that's
fascinating yeah it's very fascinating
camera we're using now
microphone room no we're in the movie
with you guys
yeah i think ninja had to re-record his
lines because his camera didn't record
properly so i think his i think his
scene in the movie has like a proper
camera in it and i was like
damn it not invested
in alexa i'm gonna get your alexa and
just mount it here for
happy wheels oh it's hilarious are you
nervous at all were you
ever nervous i mean i'm nervous now dude
i'm socially anxious as hell
every time i'm in any social situation
i'm nervous but
no it was it was definitely difficult it
was it's interesting because we were
ours
i don't know what can i say i don't know
we were ours ourselves like it says i'm
staring as lesbian so we're ourselves
but we are still involved in the
narrative
so we having to like you know read words
and like say things that aren't
our natural reaction to things but i
think that's where and that's why this
movie did things so well because the
director was so
welcoming to input he understood that he
didn't know everything
you know so if you said oh i would say
things more in this way you know and
obviously there has to be limits for a
movie i can't sit there and go f this f
that
um you know he allowed me to input on
like what i was saying in the movie
and like you know how my character acted
and stuff like that so
i think that's why it worked so well um
and why i felt so comfortable
despite it being absolutely terrifying
because he felt like he had my back the
whole way which is really cool
that's awesome so you got to be like i'm
laser beam you listen to whatever i got
to say
yeah my words this is garbage
this is terrible
[Music]
given the premise of the movie and all
that is there a particular video game if
given the opportunity you would want to
live in
[Music]
i mean i'd say oh i would say
impact oh i knew it i said oh
beautiful
the world and all the characters and
even the npcs everything is beautiful in
that game so i think i'd choose that
nice great answer ninja i do that you
know it's funny i haven't even played
that game but i've watched so many
people play it
i've watched so many people play it i
know that it's a great game
and the universe is beautiful oh i keep
saying world of warcraft because that's
what i grew up playing my entire teenage
years but i would die i would die
immediately
i mean i said this to someone else
before but i think um you know like
those
german simulators that are like just
like bus driving simulator
yeah so do that just cause it's normal
life and i probably wouldn't be eaten by
something
so it's the practical answer that's my
practical i'm i'm playing it safe guys
because i'm scared this will actually
happen
i love that you factored no one ever
factors in the reality of
like if you live in this world that it's
so true you know
i don't know i had defeating big orcs
and stuff i don't know exactly
when i drive around german streets or
something like that i
i've been in quarantine for or uh in uh
lockdown for six weeks i just want to
travel so i want to go to germany man
i'll just know that was
very cool it's a free travel trip you
know yeah i'd say for me i mean
obviously i'm straight addicted to it
right now so i'm saying
final fantasy 11 is there you go there
you go your hair is already ready to go
it's always in the middle
oh my it's got to be in a moment i'm not
trying to go
i'm going to die i'm going to get shot
i'm going to have a
i love this this was like hopping into
one of your streams this was amazing
thank you both so much for your time and
yeah the movie's incredible and you guys
rocketed it so thank you guys so much
bye
so i mean coming from for us i mean you
know coming from a background of doing
youtube
i feel like it's especially easy to be
skeptical when you see streamers pop
up in a movie and i mean i think we both
probably thought that that would be
something that pulls us
out but as the movie progresses it
really kind of helps tie things together
and it really makes it feel like yeah
the whole world is tuning in
and so you know dealing with what you
guys deal with with instant feedback and
comments coming at you were you
self-conscious at all
for what the response to just seeing you
in a huge movie would be
especially for moments where you know
you are having to be a little bit more
sincere or dramatic or
you know outside the realm of just
having fun with the game or whatever i
mean a little bit there's always going
to be
that element to it like no matter what
you do there's always going to be some
people who
feel like they've seen a little too much
of you but we've been doing it
for long enough that i think we're we're
able to kind of rise above that at this
point and
you kind of know what you're getting
yourself into you know what the reaction
is going to be
most people are incredibly nice like 90
of people are just super nice about it
and
cool super excited to go see you in a
movie like that
um but i just think i mean we just did
what was asked of us really
so if if people don't like that then
that's fine not everyone's going to
but i think for the people who are into
it and people who want to just like
go along for the ride and give
themselves over to the movie and have a
good time i think they're going to have
a blast with it
yeah and i think the way they've done it
in the film like the way they keep
cutting back to the streams as well
does really increase the suspense i
imagine if those bits weren't there
it would dramatically change the way
that story is told and how
tense that moment feels so i think
adding those moments with us in
is a positive thing for the the story in
the movie and haven't be having to be
real people like
we're not playing ex-youtuber and why
streamer we're actually playing
ourselves so i feel like it lends a sort
of
legitimacy to it that like you you kind
of get connected to the movie a bit more
almost like they are actually watching
along in real life yeah but sincerely i
know our time is up uh
it's just trippy talking to you guys
right now
and haven't you talked back not gonna
lie yeah this is so strange it's like
peering in on their streams right now
uh thank you guys so much for your time
and uh sincerely meaning you guys were
excellent in the movie you
completely wiped away all cynicism while
we were watching it you guys were great
thank you guys so much
thank you so much
i mean after being in this movie would
you want to get into more films are you
hoping this opens the door for
for more of this or you just happen to
be yourself in this one movie i
i would i would do it if people ask me
but i think i learned that i'm not an
actor
i'm not very good at reading scripted
things uh even though i was allowed to
have input
you still had to say set words because
obviously they have to
fit it all into a narrative yeah um and
i just
even when i like say want to write down
something for an intro for one of my
videos just so i remember everything i
always have to get rid of that and just
do it from memory because i can't i'm
not an actor
so i would do it if people ask me but
only if they understood that i couldn't
act going into it
[Laughter]
yeah i'd do it but just know i'm [ __ ]
like i'm terrible
so i just know that that's important to
know that honesty will get you
cash 100 percent no i think that's where
that's what uh you know casting
directors want to hear yeah i'm terrible
i'm all
terrible
i'm so honest i'm so glad to end the day
off with it with you
this is like the best this is i
appreciate it this is so awesome
i started my day with you so oh hell
yeah that's great that's great thank you
time travel it's only downhill from here
for you buddy thank you so much
easy appreciate it boys take care